my name is Colin vo I'm from Zimbabwe
I'm a member of the Young Global Leaders
and am a member of parliament in
Zimbabwe my view is that it's true the
coming of the World Cup next year will
greatly benefit the continent in three
respects firstly definitely South Africa
will have an advantage but also the
region Sadek would also benefit the
neighbouring countries depending on the
level of preparedness and also the
different countries in the continent as
long as they have already put in place a
program so that she tourists who will be
coming to see the world cup would also
spend extra days in the different
countries so that they can experience
different African cultures and also the
areas of full special interest it is my
hope that the countries should also be
in a position to put in place mechanisms
to feed themselves after the World Cup
because there will be a need to continue
with issues of economic development
having found the basis from the
investment arising from the the world
cup thank you